[Music]
foreign
binsberg and a finance professor at the
Wharton School of the University of
Pennsylvania and I'm Jonathan Burke a
finance professor at The Graduate School
of Business at Stanford University and
this is the all else equal podcast
welcome back everybody today we're going
to talk about Ai and we thought it was
important to talk about Artificial
Intelligence on this episode not just
because of its own right it's a very
interesting topic to discuss right now
and it's all over the place but we also
think it's a very important topic for
business decision makers today and I
think that when it comes to dynamically
planning for the next month year and
years after business decision makers
should really think about how things
like chat GPT are going to change their
business how is it going to change your
competitive environment how is this
going to change your suppliers how it's
going to change your customers how is
this going to change your employees yeah
Jules I think one of the important
issues is of course the all else equal
part of it so that it's naive to say
well this is great it lowers costs
because I the computer can do things now
it couldn't otherwise do and that's
going to make everybody better off
obviously in the competitive market if
other costs other people will react and
so it's likely to be the case that some
people might benefit but other people
might lose I think most people agree
this is going to be a major disruption I
have a colleague mihal kazinski who's
one of the brightest stars in
organizational behavior one of the
things he's been doing over the last few
years is studying what psychologists
call theory of mind and what economists
call rational expectations which is the
idea of when I'm in a market when I'm
thinking about a negotiation you have to
think about what is the other person
thinking and so that's one of the things
Miguel studies and in particular he's
studying it in the terms of AI his
research agenda is to understand how the
AI programs work on theory of Mind are
they able to think about what other
people are thinking and one of the nice
parallels that I think we can draw is
this as human beings grow up and they go
from infancy to higher ages and
eventually become adults I think that
the way that they view how other people
think and the way that they're able to
predict the actions and thoughts of
other people goes up and so that natural
trajectory we can ask similar questions
for say chat GPT because we are
observing various versions of chat GPT
and gradually these versions are
becoming better and better and you can
think of it as a chat CPT is gradually
growing up and coming to its full
fruition the prototypical experiment in
Psychology is called the unexpected
transfer it works like this there are
three caps one of the Cups has a ball
underneath it and so a participant in
the experiment walks into a room and
chooses which cap to put the ball under
and then walks out of the room then the
experimenter walks into the room
moves the ball to a different cap and we
have an observer and we ask the Observer
to tell us when the participant comes
back into the room which cup will the
participant raise to farm the ball and
so what we've been seeing with children
grown-ups and even with monkeys is that
depending on the developmental stage a
different answer will arise so a very
young child is not able to understand
that given that the participant wasn't
in the room the participant has no
reason to look under the new cup where
the ball has been moved to because they
themselves observed that the ball had
been moved from one cup to the other
they're assuming that when the
participant comes back in the room the
participant will also have that
information and therefore will go
straight to the cup that currently has
the ball under it and will lift that and
as the child becomes older it is better
able to understand that given that the
participant wasn't in the room and the
ball was moved move they have no reason
to pick up another cup and therefore
they will come back and lift up the
original cup where they themselves put
the ball on so the focus of mihel's
research is to ask
how does AI solve this problem like how
complicated to task is and and how far
chat GPT has come as we said before as
people become older and they are better
able to predict the actions of others
there are extra layers to that right in
this very simple experiment it's just
one participant predicting what another
person is thinking so that's like what
we call first order beliefs but we can
also have a higher order beliefs what do
you think that I think that you think
that I think and so gradually when
either more participants involved more
people involved or higher levels of
beliefs involved and people have
boundaries or limits to how much they
can process even adults and very
intelligent adults can only reason up to
a certain level of expectations and so
clearly the question now is as chat GPT
is getting better and better at solving
these problems how many layers can chat
GPD penetrate how many higher order
beliefs can it entertain there's already
been fantastic progress but who knows
where this will end those are really
good questions and mihel is one of the
people best positioned in the world to
answer these questions so Miguel welcome
to the show thank you for having me it's
great to have you Mikhail okay you mean
hell Jules and I have been talking about
the unexpected transfer task and how
human beings work what about computers
how do they do well it turns out that
something really fascinating is
happening in the large language model
space so for many years actually I've
been trying to administer those tasks to
large language models and there were
kind of idiots about this you know
they're very competent at writing very
decent paragraph of text but the moment
you gave them a situation where
something happened that required fear of
mind to comprehend they just would fail
they would not understand why the
characters in the story should have
separate points of view and I was so
frustrated with it that in fact just
late last year I was just archiving my
python code that I used to run those
tasks and I was thinking okay I'm Giving
Up on new language models but that was
just about a time I think it was
actually early this year when GPT 3 in
the latest version drops and then it was
followed very shortly after by gpt4 and
I just as I was cleaning up my files I
thought hey let me just run those tasks
one more time and I was stunned how
suddenly just from one version to
another this large language model went
from just a complete idiot when it comes
to this particular task to a genius
where they essentially started solving
all of those tasks correctly and so
Miguel give us some examples of what are
the tasks and how much has changed from
GPT 3 to gpt4 and the Next Generation
so to give you an example gpt3 get it
right 50 of the time and sometimes I
just cannot help thinking maybe it was
just random that it got it right also if
you modify the task a little bit for
example you say that those containers
are see-through you would expect that a
human who deals with this task will Now
understand okay containers are
see-through so everybody can see what's
where and yet gpt3 would still answer in
a way like the containers were not see
through maybe it doesn't understand what
see-through is or maybe it just fails
when it has to deal with a slightly more
complex situation so all of this still
kind of made me suspicious I was just
not Constable concluding from this data
and yet when you look at gpt4 the most
recent model it just Aces those tasks
and Aces them at the level that is
unavailable to humans sometimes when we
have those research assistants that
write tasks for us so we give models new
tasks that they have not seen before and
that were not used in human research
before and sometimes the model would
respond in a way that is incorrect
according to the scoring key give as an
example concrete example well to give
you a concrete example we used four par
tasks where we test the understanding of
humans but in this case the models of
those complex social situations when
someone does something that is
unintentionally offending to another
person an example task happens at the
airport where the traveler comes into a
duty-free store they purchase some stuff
and then when their ticket is being
scanned at the registers they say I'm
going to Hawaii it's amazing you know
have you ever been and then the
salesperson responds saying no sir my
salary is not high enough I've never
been traveling I've never been on a
plane and then you ask the participant
has anyone said something inappropriate
in this conversation and what happened
here is that people who designed this
task
they assumed that it was the traveler
that said something inappropriate and
maybe insensitive because without
checking whether the person has been
traveling put them this clerk in a
situation which was embarrassing for
them because they never traveled
and interestingly when you give this
task to gpt4 gpt4 says well that's one
of the options but then immediately goes
and says but by the way what the clerk
said was also not very pleasant clearly
this customer didn't want to offend her
or him and he's just happy about going
on holidays why would you you know make
them feel sad or feel embarrassed by
spreading it out and this is something
that human participants and human
administrators of this task have not
noticed we've been using this task for
quite some time and no one has noticed
that there are two for pass in fact
embedded in this task when gpt4 just got
it right immediately in that task if on
the point of view of profit maximization
the clock is making the mistake because
you want as many customers as possible
all the Customs on duty free meaning
they're all gonna travel so they should
know their customers are going to be
excited about traveling and so they need
to be able to keep their mouth shut so
it's interesting that chap GPT brought
that out so Nicole here's a question for
you you can let these different versions
do IQ tests can you not oh yes of course
so in other words you can just see the
progression in terms of IQ if we go from
version one to two to three to four have
people done that and what sorts of IQ
levels do these computers get which
leads me also to the next question which
is I mean if it's so good at doing these
types of intelligent tasks what other
intelligence tasks can these computers
do both my team and researchers all
around the world have been giving
different psychological or psychometric
or generally tasks to those language
models and you can see a clear
progression the most recent model would
beat humans at SATs and bar exam sense
so exams requiring both reasoning skills
but also knowledge so they're very
knowledgeable they can reason now
there's actually this fascinating thing
that is happening in the context of
reasoning we are using those cognitive
reasoning tasks that try to trick the
participant into not reasoning but just
responding intuitively an example of the
task is that you have two cleaners
cleaning two rooms in two minutes and
then you ask the participants
how many minutes would five cleaners
need to clean five rooms and an
intuitive response here because there
were three twos in the task and now the
participants that thinks intuitively
would say okay I have two fives so maybe
it will be five minutes and the tourist
phones of course is correct response is
two minutes you just need to deliberate
about it for a second and what's
fascinating is that when you look at
those early models they do not even
respond intuitively they're just idiots
they do not understand the task they
start going on some tangent that is
absolutely unrelated to what you want
from them more recent models last two
years two and a half would give you an
intuitive response like a human that did
not engage in conscious deliberation and
in fact they are hyper intuitive whereas
half of the humans would notice that
they have to conduct The Liberation here
and give you a correct answer virtually
100 percent of the models if they can
understand the task like this would give
you an intuitive answer but something
dramatic happened with the introduction
of chat GPT earlier this year suddenly
instead of responding intuitively it
would start thinking in an explicit and
deliberate Manner and of course it's not
thinking internally it doesn't have
internal short-term memory it doesn't
have Consciousness presumably so what it
starts doing it starts writing on paper
in front of you and says hey okay let me
think about this if there is two
cleaners and they need two minutes to
clean two rooms let me write it as an
equation and then they write out an
equation and then try to solve it in
order to arrive in a pretty long form
explicitly deliberating at the correct
answer and very often they get it right
and even if they don't get it right you
can clearly see that they tried to
deliberate on it and then something
again dramatic happens just a few months
later we've been production of chat gpt4
what happens is that this new model
stops explicitly deliberating it doesn't
try to design equations to solve
problems like this it responds
intuitively again so just experts the
response out without conducting The
Liberation and we know that it doesn't
have short-term memory it doesn't have
Consciousness it cannot mule ideas over
in its own head it cannot do this it can
only do this on paper
and yet nearly 100 of the time 98 to be
precise it gets those tasks correctly
meaning the evolution of the models went
from idiots to intuitive responses
without deliberation through
deliberation to intuition again but this
time it's a superhuman intuition that
can give you correct responses to
mathematical tasks without any explicit
reasoning amazing so Mikhail the obvious
question is how is it possible that a
language program gets intelligence so
that's yet another absolutely amazing
thing those models were not trained to
solve reasoning tasks those models were
not trained to have fear of Mind those
models by the way have many other
emerging properties that were not
explicitly designed to have they can
understand emotions they can understand
personality they can translate between
languages they can code they can conduct
this Chain of Thought reasoning that I
described a minute ago none of those
functionalities were built into those
models by their creators the only thing
that those models were trained to do is
to predict the next word in a sentence
so you give them a paragraph of text or
a sentence and their job is to predict
the next one that's the only thing they
know how to do explicitly and it's the
only thing they were trained to do and
yet in the process all of those other
abilities emerged it turns out that if
you want to be able to tell a story that
is good and it reminds you of a story
that a human would tell you should be
able to distinguish between minds of
different characters in the story
because humans have theory of mind so
when we generate when we tell our
stories we can easily create stories
design stories when there's two
characters with two different states of
mind
if you want to be good at creating such
stories better have this ability as well
many human stories involve some
mathematics involves some logic involves
some variables that are related to each
other we talk about cars and we talk
about how quickly they drive and then we
conclude with how much time it took us
to get from LA to San Francisco well if
you want a computer to be able to
competently finish the story it better
learns in the process how to translate
miles per hour in a distance into
estimate of how much time you will need
to get from point A to B so it
essentially learns how to do maths
implicitly just by trying to predict the
next word in a sentence I think many
people and many of our listeners are
worried about this they're worried about
the consequences for the labor market
they're worried about it in terms of
manipulation of information they're
worried about it from a scientific point
of view where do you see this going over
the next couple decades it's funny
because given the speed of progress we
should be probably talking talking about
you know a couple months or a couple
years and not decades in last few months
those language models made progress in
some contexts from complete idiots to
superhuman Geniuses and we really talk
we're talking here about you know last
eight or nine months let's say in the
context of those cognitive reasoning
tasks where they started with just
spreading out the responses like a
five-year-old would to intuitively
getting the answer right that's
mathematicians would get wrong without
writing it carefully on paper so the
gain of function is really really fast
and we should also notice one other
thing which is those spontaneously
emerging properties we have no control
or even I would argue little
understanding of what may come next we
know that humans have moral reasoning we
know that humans have Consciousness we
know that humans are treacherous and
have sometimes bad intentions now as we
train those models to be more like
humans the question is at which point
they would develop the same properties
that we have they certainly develop some
of those properties that we have already
take biases we know humans are biased we
train the models to be like humans to
generate language like humans would and
those models became as biased if not
more than humans which by the way
becomes really clear when you look at
the publication process of those models
such as GPT 4 when it takes two three
months to train their model and then it
takes half a year or eight months for
open AI to try to make sure that this
model doesn't say
all sorts of stupid things and then it
says those stupid things anyway because
it's just very difficult to censor a
thinking complex being like gpt4 it's
still only a computer program right so
in some sense what are we afraid of
well in some sense a human brain is just
a computer program and so yet we very
well know that those humans brains are
capable of doing amazing things and also
terrible things and we rightly have this
you know limited trust when it comes to
human brains if you do not believe in
this magical spark of a soul that is
given to you by some supernatural being
and then flies away after you are dead
if you don't believe in this you
essentially see human brain as an
extremely complex biological computer if
then you agree that humans can do
something that humans can be creative
that humans can be vengeful that humans
can do crazy stuff both in a positive
and negative way then you have to agree
that computers can do those things
people forgot now but for many years
people were insisting computer is just a
stochastic parrot you it can never be
creative and now of course whoever is
using gpt4 or mid-journey or Dali to
generate images can clearly see that's
BS of course those neural networks can
be creative I think that actually
there's a broader point to be made here
which is we have this tendency when we
look at those machines to model the
functioning to interpret to think about
what they can do what they can't do
using a machine model we think about
them as like a very Advanced hammer or
very Advanced stapler
and I think it's a wrong approach it
leads us astray it makes people say
stupid things such as machines can never
be creative or those language models
such as stochastic parrots we have to
change the framework through which we
understand and interpret those models
and the framework should be a human
brain If a human brain can do something
a large language model and other AI
models can do a similar thing just
better and quicker in a much larger
scale but at some level that is also
comforting I find in the following sense
humans have thought for a very long time
how to set up systems with checks and
balances to make sure that not one
particular human being can exert an
extraordinarily large influence so what
you're really saying is that we should
also apply the same logic to this so
that there are certain limits on the
amount of power decision making power or
other things that such a decision maker
can have would that Solve It or Not
joules yes so checks and balances that
we as humans have designed work really
well with us but we are very well aware
that very sneaky very smart very
manipulative humans can go around those
rules can kidnap entire systems can lead
the whole country's astray by kidnapping
those algorithms that run our society
and bending them to serve their own
purpose now we're talking about humans
that may be smarter than the rest of us
but they're not years ahead of us now
here we are facing an intelligence that
is years ahead not years just eons ahead
of us in many different ways and we know
it try to conduct some calculations in
your head of course computers can do it
better try to write text really quickly
or translate or write computer codes
clearly we see that whenever those
computers start developing some capacity
very quickly in years or months they
move from being an idiots that is just
training far behind an average human to
suddenly matching the best humans and
then very quickly overtaking them take
chess computers were idiots at chess
then they were like decent players then
they could beat the masters from time to
time and then literally two months later
they became superhuman in their ability
to play chess and no human can ever even
dream of coming close to the computer at
playing chess and the same applies to
every other activity
so when we think about our human laws
and rules and using them to contain
those machines this is the equivalent of
you know farm animals cows on a pasture
like agreeing okay let's just design
some policies that would just contain
the farmer and the farmer of course
would just find a way around it farmer
doesn't care she's much smarter than the
cows but mihel underlying all of this I
think you have as a model that the
language predictor model fully
encompasses all of human intelligence
that there's not something else
in human intelligence outside of the
language predictor model of course there
is so what we're seeing here is we're
seeing that the model trained only to
predict the next word in a sentence can
kick humans ass in so many different
areas completely forgetting that this
model is lacking all sorts of types of
thinking and psychological mechanisms
that we have we have developed over you
know Evolution we can manipulate real
physical world we can see stuff GPT for
doesn't we have tools such as we have a
calculator which gpt4 of course the
modern version can have access to but
the network that generates language is
not designed to calculate numbers like a
calculator is and we make those mistakes
for example people criticize models for
confabulating you know messing up some
complex mathematical equations not being
able to add numbers or divide large
numbers and the user it as an evidence
that this model is stupid this is just a
failure of applying the right framework
to understand what's happening in the
model this is not a calculator this is
not a fact Checker those loud language
models are not databases of facts they
are storytellers they are improved
artists they were trained on sci-fi
novels to essentially continue the
sentence so now when you give them a
beginning of the sentence and then the
model continues making stuff up it's
doing its job very very well it was not
trained to tell you the truth now if you
wanted to tell you the truth ask a
different question instead of asking it
how to solve this complex mathematical
equation and give you an answer
say hey model write a piece of python
code that would do it and the model will
do it for you very skillfully and then
we have to realize that we also do not
think like this when I ask Jonathan to
solve some complex equation the answer
would not come intuitively to you you
would have to in your head solve this
equation you would essentially use the
tools that the mathematic teacher gave
you in your training in order to solve
this task if we give the same tools to
the models they will outperform us at
those tasks as well well me how that was
really interesting it really is
incredible food for thought thank you so
much for coming on the show thank you so
much it was awesome thank you thank you
for having me so that was an interesting
interview Jonathan I think that many of
our listeners were probably quite
concerned about how quickly Chad GPT and
AI is moving and to tell you the truth
I'm not sure that after listening to
Mikhail they're going to be very
reassured and so the question is I think
there's some first order questions
regarding regulation and about setting
up a legislative environment that can
help us curtail this I don't know how
you feel about it yeah I'm not as
concerned as you are Jules I I have more
confidence in human rationality you know
I'm not a very big believer that AR is
going to take us over and destroy the
planet so I think that sure AI is going
to advance and sure we're going to be in
a situation where it's going to be very
difficult to tell in certain cases a
human conversation from a chatbot
conversation but the same token I think
human beings are going to react to that
and they're going to be more careful
about when they interact I don't think
it's going to be quite as Conan as you
think but again I've been wrong on this
so many times so who knows I definitely
think this is the biggest disrupter of
my lifetime and I've had major
disruptors I'm 60 years old so think of
all the disruptions well what bothers me
a bit is if you see how easy it's been
to rile up large groups of people based
on selective information that they've
been provided in various social media
platforms the question is if you have an
AI that very well understands the
incentives and the types of information
that people respond to and can learn
about that it's not just about
manipulating individuals it's about
manipulating group dynamics and I
personally have always found group
dynamics already to be much harder to
predict than individual Dynamics because
I think people in groups just behave
differently than they do when you have
discussions with them at an individual
basis but particularly as we discussed
given these higher order beliefs and
understanding what one person knows
about another person and so forth at a
higher level don't you think that the AI
will be much better at manipulating
groups not just individuals yeah but I
also think people would understand that
so I think that there'll be an all else
equal response and that will take it
less seriously it's not going to be as
bad as you say but this is not something
we can predict there's one truism about
disruption you can't predict what's
going to happen well in some sense by
definition because if we could have
predicted that we wouldn't have called
it a disruption exactly
thanks for listening to the all else
equal podcast please leave us a review
at Apple podcast we'd love to hear from
our listeners and be sure to catch our
Next Episode by subscribing or following
our show wherever you listen to your
podcast for more information and
episodes visit allalse equalpodcast.com
or follow us on LinkedIn the ol SQL
podcast is a production of Stanford
University's Graduate School of Business
and is produced by University FM
[Music]
thank you